two people are dead after a crash
involving several motorcycles and an suv
it happened in north las vegas near
cheyenne and civic drive madison
kimbrough with details for us this
morning
a crash sunday afternoon leaves two men
dead and a woman and a man in the
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries three of the motorcycles were
traveling eastbound on cheyenne
and the suv was traveling westbound on
cheyenne
two of the motorcycles left the center
roadway and crossed over to westbound
traffic
one of the motorcycle riders collided
with the suv nlvpd believes speed was a
factor in the crash all three men riding
their motorcycles said to be in their
40s to 50s while the suv driver was a
woman said to be in her 30s to 40s one
of the motorcycle riders and the suv
driver both taken to umc a local who
rides and was in the area says you have
to be even more cautious when riding a
bike on these roadways to stay safe you
have to keep your head on the swivel
you got to keep looking you got to keep
moving also stating that the motorcycle
community is very tight across the
valley no matter who they're associated
with
we don't care what club it is we are
here for each other madison kimbrough
live local now